la présidentielle le premier tour ce
dimanche prochain et oui déjà dimanche
prochain ce soir paroles de citoyens
dans le micro un jeune chef d'entreprise
nikos gère deux affaires à fondettes
après la crise du commis 19 il attend
beaucoup du prochain président tristan
et qu'il a rencontrés
[Musique]
je vais rencontrer unique aussi les
chefs d'entreprise il a 35 ans gère deux
affaires et comme beaucoup d'autres il a
souffert de la crise sanitaire sur
l'entreprise de production de spectacles
a été mise à l'arrêt alors il s'est
lancé dans la pizza depuis il gère ces
deux activités en parallèle il emploie
et manager cinq salariés dans son
restaurant d'une crise à une autre
aujourd'hui il subit de plein fouet
l'augmentation du prix des carburants et
des matières premières alors qu'attend
t'on de la présidentielle lorsqu'on est
chef d'entreprise vous voyant ça a vécu
tout de suite
ikos vous êtes propriétaire de deux
entreprises un restaurant ainsi qu'une
agence de gestion spectacle comment se
portent vos activités et bien là on sort
tout juste de la crise on a de la chance
avec la pizzeria n'a pu travailler tout
au long de la crise et puis pour les
spectacles on est dans le fameux
embouteillages annoncé dès le départ du
coup on a de la chance il ya de
l'activité c'est chouette de retrouver
tout le monde au secteur d'activité
respectif la restauration ainsi que
l'événementiel ont été particulièrement
impacté par par écrit du coc vide avez
vous le sentiment d'avoir été
suffisamment soutenue par l'état pour
moi tout cas oui tant sur la partie
gestion de sociétés on a été accompagné
sur tout un tas de paliers différents
et puis sur la gestion du social aussi
on a pu conserver nos emplois avec le
chômage partiel quelles sont vos
attentes auprès du ou de la future
présidence de la république à quelques
semaines de ce premier tour ce qui
m'intéresse le plus à l'heure actuelle a
aujourd'hui
lever un maximum tout ce qui concerne
les freins à la gauche qu'on puisse
embaucher plus et derrière ça baisser
les charges salariales afin qu'on puisse
payer mieux nos salariés et faire face à
l'inflation
[Musique]